So, how does Google give feedback for
new Google apps?
Even before internal testing
among employees, or dogfooding,
each app goes to the Google
User Experience review process.
The goal of this process is to get the
app in front of experienced Googlers to
focus on various parts of the user
experience, such as design,
interaction patterns,
accessibility, and more.
As we looked into productionizing
Sunshine, we wanted to get some expert
help with the UI that would
both leverage a broader set of
implementations skills than we were
able to present in the first course.
And begin to illustrate
a material design concepts.
Of course we turned to Android UX legend
Roman Nurik who has helped many Android
developers improve the UX of their
applications with direct feedback.
Develop design tools to make
constructing Android UX easier.
And who has contributed DashClock and
Muzei to the Android world.
[SOUND] Roman, it's so
great to have you here with us.
Now, when you first looked at
Sunshine from Android Fundamentals,
what are the things that you felt
worked really well in the design?
>> So, let me take out my phone and
just point them out.
So, I think that the first thing
that was done really well was just
the use of hierarchy, or
the overall hierarchy of the screen.
Yeah you have your branding on top and
then you have
the most important piece of information,
the current conditions and
weather, at the top as well in this
kind of nice, big display type.
And then below that you have the
secondary information, the forecast for
tomorrow and the next day and so on.
That was one.
I think another that was done
really well is the use of keylines.
So keylines are essentially these
invisible vertical rules that
you can use to align
streams of information.
And it felt like specifically the use of
that second keyline, the one where you
have the brand name, the current
temperature, the dates of the kind
of later forecast, those are kind of
left aligned to that second keyline.
And I feel like that is
really nice in helping
visually process the information very,
very quickly.
So I feel like those are probably
two of my favorite aspects of
the existing design.
>> Tell us a bit about what you designed
in the new production version of
Sunshine, and why.
>> Well,
I think I'll just talk about one,
I think that there's one that's
really important here, and
it's an essential part of material
design, and that's the use of surfaces.
So the first is I felt that, well, with
surfaces, I guess, in the existing app,
you kind of, I guess the use of
surfaces was all over the place.
On portrait phone screens,
on landscape tablet screens,
it wasn't really consistent.
It felt like information was being
presented in different ways.
And what's worse, on landscape tablet's,
you actually had this kind of
massive sea of white space.
And the information was kind
of floating on top of that.
And it felt like the use
of surfaces can really help
both manage that white space,
and introduce consistency.
And so in the new design,
we use this single elevated white card
to present the current conditions of,
I guess the current temperature, right?
And we use that consistently
across phones and tablet's.
And so, that does three things.
The first is that, again, it
introduces consistency across screens.
The second is it that actually
makes it easier to do motion to,
another big part of
shell design is motion.
It helps you do things like
transition from list to detail.
When you can kind of have a single
object that appears in both and
transition them,
it's really nice and easy.
And I guess the third is it really
kind of helps you manage space.
On that landscape tablet screen, the
fact that you can have this kind of nice
big card to present one
major stream of information.
And kind of have everything else fall,
I guess, from outside of that.
It makes a nice use of space, I guess.
I mean just very bluntly,
it's a really nice use of that
massive screen real estate.
And so it does those three
things really well I think.
And that's one of the things that we
really focus on in this redesign for
Sunshine.
>> [SOUND] Wow, tons of great feedback.
Like we expected,
we have a really good start.
But there are some rough edges to work
through before we have a production
ready user experience.
So, how does that constructive feedback
map to our production quality goals?
Well, the design feedback we got
around consistency, white space, and
motion fall under [INAUDIBLE].
Those little details can really
make Sunshine stand out.
When you combine that with
the suggestions Team FixIT has made,
such as under Simplify My Life, having
Sunshine display useful information,
even when there's no network
connectivity or poor user input.
And under Make Me Amazing,
having Sunshine open up new,
extremely useful ways of getting
weather information front and center.
We had some pretty good ideas about
how to start getting us closer
to the production of Sunshine.